KATHRYN HURLEY: Hey everyone.
Welcome to I/O.
I'm so excited to be here.
I hope you are too.
My name's Kathryn Hurley.
I'm a developer programs
engineer at Google.
Specifically, I work
on Fusion Tables.
And I'm here today along with
James McGill, an engineer on
the Maps API team, and Simon
Rogers, from the UK
Guardian data blog.
And today we're going to be
talking to you about to how to
use Fusion Tables to manage and
visualize geospatial data.
So this is the agenda
for the talk.
I'm going to give you an
introduction to Fusion Tables.
Then I'll run through
a quick demo of how
to use Fusion tables.
Then I'll talk to you about
how you can build an
application using the
Fusion Tables API.
Then James is going to talk
about Google Maps API and how
you can you Google Maps API to
display your Fusion Table data
on a Google Map.
And finally, Simon Rogers is
going to show you some
real-world examples of how the
Guardian is using Fusion
Tables to display their
data on Google Maps.
And we're really excited to see
how journalists are using
Fusion Tables.
All right, so intro
to Fusion Tables.
When people ask me what is
Google Fusion Tables, I like
to say that it's a database in
the cloud that you can use to
store, host, collaborate on,
and visualize your data.
Here's a nice example of a
visualization that you can
create using Fusion Tables.
This is a map.
And this map was actually
created by Simon Rogers.
It's showing deprivation
in England.
You can see he did some
nice styling of the
polygons on the map.
You can also see that the info
windows were customized and
this was all built using
Fusion Tables.
All right, here's another
example of a visualization you
can create using
Fusion Tables.
This is a bar chart created
using the Google
Visualization API.
Fusion Tables acts as
a data source in the
Visualization API.
I'm not going to go into too
much detail here about how to
use the Visualization API, but
I encourage you go to the
session "Using Chart Tools to
Create Interactive Dashboards"
that's occurring right after
this one in room one.
And you can learn more about the
Visualization API there.
So now I just want to actually
jump into a quick demo of how
to use Fusion Tables.
I can show you a lot of screen
shots of what the product
looks like, but I think it's
more interesting if I actually
show you a real-life demo
of the product.
And there's also some really
cool things that you can do in
the Fusion Tables web
application that I just wanted
to show you how to do.
And so, for example, you can
merge two tables together in
the Fusion Tables
web application.
Merging is basically a left out
or join if you're familiar
with databases.
You can also manage the
permissions and visibility of
the tables that you own in
Fusion Tables using the web
application.
And you can also create a map
and customize that map with
custom info windows
and map styles.
So I'm just going to get out of
full-screen mode right now
and go to Fusion Tables.
And this is probably a little
bit small, so I'm going to
increase outside here.
All right, so I go to
google.com/Fusiontables, I've
signed in with my gmail account,
and I'll see a list
of the tables that I own.
I'm going to work with these
two tables down here at the
bottom: Ecoregion Boundaries
and Ecoregion Attributes.
So let's look at the Ecoregion
Boundaries table.
So this table contains the
boundaries of various
ecoregions around the world.
Ecoregions are basically areas
that have the same climate and
plant and animal species
within them.
So we got this data from
The Nature Conservancy.
They were very nice and
shared this data
with us for this demo.
The Nature Conservancy is
concerned with preserving
Earth's natural resources, so
they have a lot of data about
the ecoregions around
the world.
And this table was created from
a KML file that they had
containing all the ecoregion
boundaries
throughout the world.
And this is just a subset of
that data, it's the ecoregions
in Australia.
So let's take a look and
see what this table
looks like on a map.
So Fusion Tables maps all the
polygons that were in that KML
file and places it on
it a Google Map.
When you click on one of these
features, you can see what's
displayed in the info window.
You can see that the data from
the table is displayed in the
info window.
OK, let me go over to the other
table that I have the
ecoregion attributes.
Now this data was also donated
to us from The Nature
Conservancy.
And the cool thing about The
Nature Conservancy is that
they work with a lot of
different organizations.
So, for example, they work
with the World Wildlife
Foundation.
And all these organizations have
specific data about the
ecoregions around the world.
So, for example, The Nature
Conservancy has information
about the percent forest area
in ecoregions, and the World
Wildlife Foundation has
information about maybe the
number of lizards and snakes in
each of these ecoregions.
So Fusion Tables allow a lot of
these organizations to work
together to collaborate
on this data.
So The Nature Conservancy can
upload their own table with
their own data so that the WWF
can upload their table and
have their own data up
in Fusion Tables.
And then they can merge these
tables together to create one
huge Table or merge Table.
So I'm going to show you
how to merge two tables
together right now.
I'm going to merge the attribute
table with the
boundary table.
So I just copied the URL from
the attribute table.
I'll go back to the boundary
table and select Merge.
I'll paste in the URL from the
other Table, click that.
Now at this point I want to
select the two columns that
have the same values in it.
So this is similar to keys and
databases, both columns have
to have the same value.
And the two columns in my
table are the object ID
column, so I'll select both of
those, and I'll called this
new merged table that I'm
creating Ecoregions Merged.
When I'm done here, I click
Merge Tables, and Fusion
Tables will work and it creates
this new merged table.
And you can see that the data
from both tables are in this
merged table.
So I'll scroll over so you can
see more columns here.
And the nice thing about this
merged table is that if any of
the data in the base tables that
were used to create the
merged table are updated, then
those updates are immediately
reflected in the merged table.
So let's say that the WWF finds
a new lizard species,
they can go ahead and update
that data in their table and
it'll be reflected in
this merged table.
Now let's see what this
looks like on the map.
Select visualized map and
occasionally might see a
loading message.
It takes a little bit of time
for the data to load.
I'll just refresh the
page and let's see
that on the map again.
And there you can see our nice
boundaries on the map.
And I'll click on one of these
polygons so you can see the
information that's being
displayed in the info window
and you can see it displaying
all the information from my
table in this info window.
But maybe I don't want to show
all this information.
Maybe I just want to show the
name of the ecoregion and the
forest area, so I'm going to
update the contents of the
info to just show the
information that I want.
In order to do that, I can click
Configure Info Window
and I can select and deselect
which columns I want displayed
in the Info window.
Or I can also go to Custom
and edit the HTML.
So I can really customize
the contents of the
Info window even more.
So I'm going to delete that
label, maybe give this nice
color blue, and add the
closing tag here.
And save. And let's see what
happened to our info.
There you can see now the name
of the ecoregion is bold and
blue and shows just the percent
forest area in the
Info window.
So an all-red map maybe
not that useful.
Let's actually change the
styles of these features
according to the information
that's showing in my Info
window, basically the
percent forest area.
So in order to do that,
I can configure the
styles for the table.
And you can see there are
several options for changing
the style of the features
on the map.
If you have points, you can
change the marker icon.
Or you can change the
fill color of the
polygons, et cetera.
Since my data is polygons,
I'm going to
change the fill color.
And again, you can see there's
several options for changing
the fill color of
the polygons.
I'm going to go ahead and
select a gradient.
I'm going to show a gradient
on percent forest area--
that's the data I'm showing
in my Info window.
And I can customize the colors
of the gradient.
I'll make it a nice
teal color.
And I'll set the min and max for
the range of the data in
the Percent Forest
Area column.
I'll click Save. And you can
see our map is immediately
updated with the new styles.
And I'll click on one of these
regions and you can see that
the Info window content
is the same.
All right, this is
really awesome.
And at this point, I'll show
you how to share the table
with others, because after
you've put all this hard work
into your map, you probably
want to share
it with other people.
So these permissions are
similar to Google Docs
permissions.
You can invite specific people
to view or edit the table, or
you can set the visibility of
the entire table to public,
unlisted, or private.
I will set this as unlisted
so people that have the
link can view it.
And at this point,
I could be done.
I could click Get an
Embeddable Link.
I grab this HTML, I'll copy it,
paste it in my own HTML
page, and I'll have this map
directly in my website.
So it's how I styled it in
Fusion Tables, how I set the
Info window contents, that'll
be available in my website.
So you can do a lot of cool
things in the UI.
All right, go back.
So I showed you how to merge two
tables, I showed you how
to manage the permissions and
the ability of the table, I
showed you how to create a map
and customize that map.
Now how might you build
an application
using Fusion Tables?
Here are a couple
of application
ideas I came up with.
Some of these are actually being
developed right now.
One developer is mapping out
newspapers around the world.
It's a really cool
application.
He's styling the markers
according to the language of
the newspaper.
He's updated the contents of
the Info windows to provide
links to the online content
for these newspapers in
various translations
so you can read it
in English or Spanish.
And he's allowing his users to
search for newspapers around
their area.
Another cool application I've
heard of Fusion Tables is a
popular game manufacturer was
interested in finding out
which servers their users
were connecting to.
And using Fusion Tables,
they were easily
able to map this out.
And they were surprised to find
that a lot of their users
in North America
were connecting
to servers in Europe.
And they really wanted those
users to connect to servers in
North America.
And they were easily able
to figure that out
using Fusion Tables.
So they uploaded the data and
they could immediately map it
out on a map.
So let's just go through a work
flow of what one of these
applications might look like.
So let's go through the mapping
newspapers around the
world application.
So let's say you wanted to
create this application and
you want users to be able to use
your application and enter
information about their own
local newspapers into your
application.
So you could create a web form
and or Android or mobile
application, and this
application would enter data
directly into Fusion Tables.
And at this point, it's really
easy to create a visualization
of the information that's being
submitted to your table.
You just simply visualize
it on a map.
And here's an example of
a map that you can
create with this data.
You can color the markers
according to the language or
some other attribute
of the newspaper.
I'll click on one of these.
You can see that it has name of
newspaper-- and these are
all just fake newspapers
I made up--
and you can provide a link
directly to the newspaper.
Alright, so now let's go through
the details of the API
so you know how to use
the API to build an
application like this.
The API is a REST API, so
basically that means you can
make HTTP requests
to Fusion Tables.
With these requests, you
send SQL-like queries.
In order to create table
inserts, collect to update
data, et cetera.
And here's just a few examples
of the queries
that you can send.
You can see where creating a
new newspaper table with
columns for the name of the
newspaper, location of the
newspaper, and a link
to the newspaper.
And we're inserting data,
selecting, et cetera.
And OAuth is used for
authorization.
And here's just some
sample code.
This is written in Thai Puan,
but you can write your code in
any language that you
want as long as it
can make HTTP requests.
So you can see I'm creating a
query that's creating a new
table under the newspaper
table.
And it's sending the query along
with the request. And
depending on the query that
I'm sending, you'll get
different data back.
So if I send the Create Table
query, then I'll get this
Table ID back if the create
was successful.
OK, so now I just want to jump
over to a demo of the API.
So let me just go over to
a terminal real quick.
And this looks a little
bit small.
And something happened to
my [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Sorry, let me just find where
it is real quick.
Sorry about this.
I should have prepared this
a little bit better.
OK, so I have a Python file.
And let me just initiate
Python here.
And it's a little bit small.
Let me increase the font so
I can see this better and
increase the window.
OK.
So I have a Python file
and exchange a
Fusion Tables class.
And in this class, I can make
requests to Fusion Tables and
I'll send various queries
to Fusion Tables.
So I have a Show Table query,
Create Table query, et cetera.
And so I'm just going to go
ahead and import that Fusion
Tables class.
And I'll create a new
instance of that.
And I'll run the Show
Tables query.
And you can see the
tables that I own.
You might recognize some of
these tables from earlier.
It has the Ecoregion table.
And let me go ahead and
create a new table.
So I'm running the Create
Table query.
I'm creating a new newspapers
table and initializing the
three columns, the name,
location, and link.
OK, so let's just run
a describe on this.
And you can see the results
of the describe.
It's describing the table,
showing the columns and the
data types for each
of these columns.
OK.
And this is sort of mimicking
the stuff that you would do if
you wanted to write your
newspapers application using
Fusion Tables.
So let's enter some data into
this table because right now
it's just an empty table.
And so this step is going to
mimic how your users would be
able to submit information
to a Fusion Table.
So you run insert statements
when somebody submitted a form
on your web application or
in your Android app.
And so we're inserting
information about various
newspapers around Bay Area:
San Jose Mercury News,
Mountain View Voice,
et cetera.
So let's run a Select
query on the table.
And now you can see that the
data is in my table.
We have information about San
Jose Mercury News, et cetera,
and it might be hard to see--
maybe I'll increase this one
more time-- but the link at
the bottom is actually
incorrect.
The San Francisco Chronicle's
URL is not SGATE, it's SFGATE,
and this is pretty common if
you're writing an application
that does crowd sourcing.
Maybe your users are submitting
erroneous data, or
maybe changes to the
data are occurring.
Maybe the San Francisco
Chronicle has changed the URL
to their website.
So you want to be able
to update that data.
And so we have an Update
Statements.
We've sent the Update Statement,
we've set the new
link to the new value and
specified the row ID that we
want to update.
And you can see that.
Now our data is being updated
and let's run a Select one
more time so you can
see the results.
Now the URL for SFGATE
has been updated.
Also an interesting addition
to this might be adding a
Spatial query.
So Fusion Tables for
Spatial queries.
This will allow your users
to find newspapers
that are near them.
So you can find the N nearest
features or you can find all
the features that fall within
a circle or a bounding box.
So you can find the closest
newspapers to your user.
All right, so that's the API
demo just showing you how you
might use Fusion Tables to build
a newspaper application.
All right, so now I just wanted
to announce a couple
new features.
We're very excited about
these new features.
We are now releasing to trusted
testers map feature
styling and Info window
customization, all available
in the API.
So I showed you how to do these
steps in the UI earlier.
I showed you how to style the
features is on the map of the
ecoregions and also update
the Info windows.
Now you can do this
in the API.
So this is really exciting.
I just want to mention
real quick how to
become a trusted tester.
Just send an email to this
mailing list. This email will
show up later in the
presentation, so don't worry
if you don't copy it
down right now.
We'll show it again.
And how do these new
features work?
This is a rest API similar
to the S2L API that
I showed you earlier.
So you can make HTP requests to
insert, delete, update the
styles and Info window
templates.
JSON objects represent the
styles and the Info window
template for your table.
This is an example a JSON object
representing the styles
of table one, two, three,
four, five.
It's setting all the markers
to small blue icons.
And so why is this awesome?
This is really great if you're
creating lots of tables.
So I was recently working with
the census data, and there's a
ton of census data.
I think I created around
200 different tables.
And if I wanted to go into the
UI and update the styles for
all these tables, it would take
a very, very long time.
So what I can do instead now is
use the API to create the
table and then immediately apply
a style or custom Info
window to this table.
Why?
It's just in the code,
so it saves a lot of
time in these cases.
These new features are also
really cool because you can
find out how public cables
are being styled.
So if you really like how the
Guardian styled their
deprivation map, you can use the
API to find out the style
of that table and potentially
reuse it for your own table.
Also a cool new feature of these
new features of the API
is that it's part of the Google
API console, and with
the API console you get
a lot of nice things.
For example, you see your quote
and you can also get
analytics about your
API usage.
So if you're getting close to
your quota, then you can
adjust your code.
Also, these new features are
ported in the Google client
libraries, and that makes
requests to the APIs much
easier and it makes it
much easier as well.
And again, I just want to
reiterate that trusted testers
are needed.
Here's the email list. And we'll
show this later in the
presentation as well.
OK.
Now, at this point, I've shown
you how to do the back end of
Fusion Tables.
James is going to take it away
and show you how to use map
API to show your Fusion
Table data on a map.
And he's flown all the way from
Sydney, by the way, to
talk to you guys.
He's excited to be here.
JAMES MCGILL: Good afternoon,
everybody.
Thank you very much for coming
to our presentation today, as
Kathryn mentioned, I have flown
in all the way from
Sydney, but it's been absolutely
worth it, I'm
having just a great day.
And I'm excited to be talking to
you today because what I'm
really interested in as an API
programmer is making it easy
for developers to show large
amounts of geographic
information on a map in their
own websites in a way to easy
for them and useful to the
people visiting their website.
And I'm really excited about
Fusion Tables, because Fusion
Tables makes this very simple.
As I mentioned before, I'll be
talking about the Google Maps
JavaScript API.
Now this is a JavaScript API
used by developers all over
the internet.
It makes it simple to add an
interactive SlippyMap like you
might have seen on
maps.google.com to any
third-party site with just a
few lines of JavaScript.
But what developers may struggle
with a little bit
more is getting their
data onto that map.
Now, I'm kind of a crime buff,
and I happen to have some data
that shows the locations of
crimes all over Chicago.
And I have a map of Chicago.
Using Fusion Tables, I can
combine these two things with
only five lines of code.
All I need is the name of a
column in a Fusion Table that
represents my geographic data.
Now this column should contain
features like latitude and
longitude points or polygons
or polylines.
I also need the ID
of the title.
If you're not sure how to get
the ID, that's contained
within the URL.
So you can just copy that out
of the URL, highlighted in
blue in these slides, and
paste it in the layout.
And with those five lines
of code, I get a map
that looks like this.
Right?
Very simple.
And I can convey a large amount
of information to the
people who view my site.
Now of course I can also filter
that information.
So, for example, I may only want
to display crimes that
have occurred where the victim
was over 50 years old.
I use those same five lines as
before, but I dynamically,
when I click this button, add
an additional property to
filter them out.
And the map updates instantly.
And now we're only showing the
subset of the information that
the person viewing our site
is interested in.
Of course, you can set this
programmatically as well.
So you can let the people
visiting your site decide
exactly what subset
of data they're
interested in looking at.
So why use Fusion
Tables Layer?
Both of the things I just showed
you are possible using
the Fusion Tables UI.
Kathryn demonstrated before that
you can extract an Embed
link that you can use to embed
an interactive map in your
site without having to
write any JavaScript.
But as developers, we often want
to customize the behavior
of the sites that we build.
We want them to stand apart
from the crowd.
And a Google Maps API allows
you to do this.
In the next couple of examples,
I'm going to use a
table I found publicly available
in Fusion Tables
about coffee production around
the world for various
countries over the
last five years.
Using that code I showed you
before, it's very simple to I
add this data to a map.
By default, if you click one of
these features, what will
happen is that the default
Google Maps Info window is
displayed and it's filled with
whatever Info window content
was configured through the UI.
However, through the UI
you're effectively
limited to static HTML.
Now if we want to do something
just a little bit more fancy,
because the Maps API has
additional options on the
Layer and allows us to customize
behavior, we can
achieve that.
So in this example, I set
Suppress Info Windows to true,
which tells the API to no longer
display the default
Info window.
And I also add a Click Handle.
Now the Click Handle function
will be called whenever a user
clicks on a feature
in the map.
And this allows me to inject my
own customized code to deal
with this event.
So let's see what happens
when we click this time.
It's just a little
bit different.
And what's particularly cool
here is that when you click on
a feature, it not only gives you
back the location of that
feature, but it also gives you
back the contents of the row
in the table associated
with that feature.
In this case, I get back an
array containing integer
values about coffee
production.
And I can process that in
JavaScript, pass it off to the
Google Charts API, and create
my dynamic chart.
Which makes it easier for people
viewing this site to
interpret this data.
Of course, you can also combine
this with other
features in the Maps API.
For example, Styled Maps, which
I've used to here to
customize the appearance of the
base map, remove a lot of
the saturation, make it all very
simple, and make the data
that I'm showing to the
user really stand out.
Let's flip things around a
little bit and talk about why
you would use Fusion Tables in
the Maps API instead of some
of the all the built-in
functionality.
Now, if you've used the Google
Maps API before, you'd know
that you can use JavaScript
to create markers.
And markers can be placed on
the surface of the Earth to
annotate a point.
However, there's one problem
with markers.
Even though we've worked
extremely hard to ensure that
you can display between 100 and
1,000 markers very, very
quickly, they still must
be created in a client.
This means creating JavaScript
objects and the responsibility
of rendering these
markers most be
performed by a browser.
Now these are some measurements
I've taken using
a relatively modern machine and
a modern browser sometime
in the last week.
As you go from 1,000 to
100,000 markers, the
performance of the client-side
marker degrades significantly.
And it can take up to 40 seconds
to display all those
markers on a map.
Now, if you use Fusion Tables
Layer, you can display the
same number of markers
in under a second.
And that's really compelling,
especially on mobile devices
with slower APUs and less RAM.
The user of your site is going
to notice the performance
difference.
This is achieved with
tiled rendering.
The data in the Fusion Tables
database is rendered in the
cloud by Google servers.
It renders transparent image
overlays, which is sent down
and put on the top
of your map.
The net result is that we need
only 40 tiles or so to display
any map regardless of the number
of features shown.
So your map can scale from 100
features to 1,000 features to
100,000 features without you
needing to think through the
performance implications.
And this is, I think,
particularly compelling for
developers.
Now there's one more thing
I want to talk about.
I want to talk about adding
a little bit of
style to your map.
Now this is something Kathryn
touched on before.
Adding styling information to
your map is not only important
to make your map look good but
also to convey important
semantic information about the
data represented on your map.
Here's a map where I've gone
into the Fusion Tables UI and
I've styled the map to show
areas within Australia that
have fewer than 250 unique
species of birds in green and
areas with more than 250
unique species in blue.
But as a developer, I know that
I'm not always in the
best position to decide what
people visiting my site are
interested in.
The next person to view my site
may not care about the
difference between 250 species
but maybe the split between
300 species or 350 species,
which is why I'm excited today
to announce that you can now
dynamically update the styles
on a Fusion Tables Layer using
the JavaScript API.
So if I drag the slider here
to 300, and that will be
restyled to represent
this information.
Now this is great, because you
can now have users interact
with your site, tell you what
they're interested in knowing
about your map, and restyle
your map to convey that
information in a way that's
very easy for them to see.
So how is this done?
It's very basic.
We've added a style property
to the Fusion Tables Layer.
This takes in an array of
styling objects which can be
used to customize the appearance
of your map.
We'll start with a
simple example.
This one is a simple styling
object that sets all polygons
to have a green fill.
If you put this on your
map, you get something
that looks like this.
But we can combine this with
other styling objects.
So let's add another element
to our array.
This one is a restricted
style.
We've added a Where clause,
which means that this style
will only apply to elements that
match the condition of
having more than 300 unique
species of birds
associated with them.
In this case, we're going to
set the fill color to blue.
Now if we combine this in the
array with our previous style,
both styles will be applied in
order with later styles taking
precedence where
they conflict.
In this case, on the definition
of the fill color
for a polygon.
So now we get something like
what I showed you before.
But we can do something
even cooler.
Styles cascade in the same
way that you would
expect CSS styles to.
So if you don't provide a full
definition for a style, it
will inherit elements
of that style from
previously matched features.
So let's restrict this to
features that have a
population of more than five
people per square kilometer.
And in this case we're going
to set the full opacity to
one, where it previously
was about half.
Now this is going to cascade
with our previous style, so
we're going to see a couple of
distinct types of features.
Some features are green with 50
percent opacity, these are
where there are fewer than
five people per square
kilometer and also fewer than
250 species of birds.
Some features are blue with
full opacity, and this is
where there are more than five
people per square kilometer
and more than 300 unique
species of birds.
And already this map
is conveying useful
information to me.
Everybody loves the east coast
of Australia, right?
Just by glancing at this map,
we can tell the highest
concentrations of both people
and unique species of birds is
along the east coast
of Australia.
So by combining these styles,
we can represent multiple
different strata of information
on a single map.
I think that's really cool.
And the final point
is that this can
be dynamically updated.
The styles, arrays, and NDC
property, which means in the
Maps API JavaScript, if you
update that property at any
time, the map will automatically
update to
represent the new state.
So let's have a look at
a little example.
Maybe I'm a little bit over
birds now; I'm more
interested in plants.
So we'll create a new style that
colors the map red where
we have more than 1,000 unique
species of plants.
We're also going to create a
function called Update Style,
which is going to read back our
previous definition of the
style, which is this
array we parsed in.
It's going to override the first
style and array with
this new style about coloring
the map red
where we have plants.
And we're just going to
hook that up to a
Button on our map.
Every time someone clicks that
button, this code is going to
run, the property will be
updated, and the map will
automatically update to
reflect this change.
So click this button,
three colors.
Right?
This is great, because as I
said before, you're now no
longer limited to deciding
exactly what you're going to
show your users in advance, but
instead allow them to sift
through the information that
you can make available
publicly on your website and
extract exactly what they're
interested in.
Couple of pitfalls.
As I showed you before, you
can restrict what data is
shown by parsing in
a Where clause as
part of a query object.
In this example, I've restricted
the data to only
show elements that have
fewer than 100
unique species of birds.
But I've also very cleverly
decided to add a style that
only applies when there's more
than 100 hundred unique
species of birds.
Obviously that style isn't
going to take effect.
Just something to
watch out for.
Of course, in all these demos,
I've shown polygon styles.
You can also style other
elements of the map.
You can control the border
thickness, color, and opacity
for polygons.
You can control the thickness,
color, and opacity for
polylines, which you could use,
for example, to represent
routes, so driving routes.
And you can also control the
appearance of markers or
points by selecting from
the set of icons
offered by Fusion Tables.
Couple of things
worth knowing.
Styles can be applied
to any table, not
just tables you own.
So you can take someone else's
data and, without owning that
table and Fusion Tables or
needing to clone it, restyle
it on your own website to
represent what you're
interested in.
And you don't have to worry
about the styles on that
changing underneath you because
you can always ensure
that you control the
default appearance.
With Fusion Tables Layer,
you can have up to
five styles per layer.
And you can have up to five
different layers per map, one
of which can contains
styling information.
And this is still part
of the Maps API
experimental features.
We wanted to push this out so
that you as developers can get
started playing with it.
There might be a few bumps in
the road, but we're working
hard to ensure that this works
as stably as possible.
And even more exciting,
this is live today.
The reference should have
gone out sometime
in the lost 10 minutes.
So you can start building
website that use this feature
as soon as you leave
this room.
[APPLAUSE]
And now I'm going to pass over
to our guest, Simon, from the
Guardian data blog.
He's going to talk about how
he's been using Fusion Tables
out there in the real world
to help build his sites.
[APPLAUSE]
SIMON ROGERS: Hi.
I feel a bit of a fraud here
because all you people here
actually make things, and I'm
not one of the people that
makes things, I just take
advantage of things that other
people make.
But we do use Fusion Tables
quite a lot, and we're just
scratching the surface
of what's possible.
I'm personally aware of that.
I'll explain a bit about what we
do and then how we use it.
So I edit something called the
Datablog and the Datastore,
and what we do is every day
we just publish raw
data around the news.
So, for instance, this is the
site today, so we just had
this UN report that projects
the population to 2100.
And we'll take that data, we'll
make it more accessible.
We publish it using Google
spreadsheets because that's
such a good way to share data.
And we'll show visualizations,
we use Fusion Tables quite a
lot for that.
And these guys did this
stuff for us.
So we put our data out there.
And we put it out there so other
people can then do stuff
with it and give
it back to us.
And I suppose the reason for
that is because nowadays
nobody trusts journalists.
And they rarely trust what
we're telling them.
So we can say, well, this is
the data behind the story.
We can make that story real and
we can bring it to life.
I suppose it came out of the
fact that we were just
accumulating all this data.
And there's so much data, raw
information out there.
So much of it is available in
totally inaccessible formats:
in PDFs or badly formatted
documents.
We've got something called the
Office of National Statistics
in the UK, which publishes tons
of data, but they're used
to publishing books.
So the published data as it
was in the book was all
formatted preferably with lots
of lines and merged cells and
stuff, which is no good if
you actually want to do
anything with it.
So I guess the reason we came
across Fusion Tables was
because like a lot of places,
we have a real
kind of time famine.
We have a lot of developers
who are really busy on
creating enormous things.
Actually, if you want something
built, you have to
really justify it.
And I can't really justify my
getting my map built compared
so building the iPad for the
Guardian, or whatever.
So you've got to justify
maps, then.
So we just came across
Fusion Tables.
And at first, when somebody told
me about Fusion Tables, I
didn't really get it.
I didn't understand whether
it was a spreadsheet.
It wasn't really a spreadsheet
and it wasn't really--
so I didn't understand it until
somebody said, oh it's a
really good way for
making maps.
And that's how we got into it.
And this is one of the
first things we did,
which was the blitzes.
people and you code that's with
the Second World War some
in general in the blitzes, in
particular, was a big attack
on London in the year of 1940.
And it turns out that basically
the London fire
brigades kept these records
during the blitz, which are
all kept in the London
Metropolitan Archives in a
great big book, obviously.
Neatly tied records.
Every time the fire brigade
was called out to a bomb,
somebody would go back and
tie a record after.
It was pretty amazing,
considering what were were
going through at the time.
And we thought well, we should
just take our data--
and there was too much data
to record for every day.
There was 800 days of this.
But what there was was we
thought, let's take the first
night of the blitz and we
created this list here.
And all we had for this list
was we had a time, we had a
location with a street
address.
And that street address would be
a street address that might
not exist anymore or would
be a partial post code.
Every street, you have
zip codes here.
Every street has a post
code in the UK.
And you might just get
a partial address.
That street there, Suffolk
Street, that might not exist.
So what we did was we did this
table, we put it in, then we
thought let's try a Fusion
Table, and see what it does.
And because it works like
Google Maps works, it
basically found 95 percent of
those addresses just by having
the first name of the address,
and we added London, UK
because it seemed to just
default to America otherwise.
And it would collect 95 percent
of the addresses and
then we could correct the
ones that were missing.
So of the 300 places, you could
then find the other ones
that were missing and
easily adjust them.
The fact that we
could do that.
And you create something,
then, which brings
that data to life.
And it means that you can
see what happened.
And people were going on there
and exploring the data and
saying that's why there's
a new building at
the end of my street.
That's what happened there.
It's a really nice way for us
to be able to display that
data and make it real
for people.
And do something online that
takes advantage of the
features that you've
got there.
This is something else where
we've got a lot of data.
The other thing that we'll
discuss in the UK are school
results, especially on parents
obsessed with where my
daughter is going to go
in five years' time.
And the government every
year releases
secondary school results.
And they release it with the
school name and a post code
and an ID for that school.
So if she's got an ID for that
school, something we can start
mashing that data together and
bring it in with other data.
And they also release data on
how much you spend for each
pupil in each school with the
same ID codes on separate
sheets So we can bring
that stuff together.
And we can do stuff like this,
which it what goes in the
paper which shows the spread by
local authority across the
UK of how much is spent
on these pupils.
But the really cool thing about
bringing all of those
schools into a Fusion Table it
really brings it to life to
people online.
Again in a way that--
I could do that--
in a way that we wouldn't
be able to do otherwise.
To be able to have each of these
schools that you can
then click on and you can
find your school.
And we started zooming
into where I live,
which is down here.
Let's see if I can
zoom in to that.
So each of these dots is
a secondary school.
And secondary school in the UK
is where you go to from 10 to
18, and you do A levels
there and so on.
And the fact that you can get
really close there-- let me
just find our school.
And for each school you've got,
you can pull all that
stuff up and you can say how
much-- so that school there is
8,000 pounds per pupil.
And you've got the results there
and you can start to
compare real-life data and
actually tell you something in
a useful way for us to be able
to make that data come alive
for people.
But then to just use it in a
standard way every day is
really useful too.
So when they had the Fukushima
accident in Japan, being able
to pair our data and
then use it.
To So you can highlight
different events-- let's just
go to the full-screen one,
but that's too small--
but the fact that they store
this stuff up and they pick on
different places is just a
really useful thing for us.
And we can update this
and add to it and it
will display on it.
Because traditionally--
and this might sound what
you guys want--
every time we've done a map
online, has meant somebody in
Flash manually drawing each
place or drawing each border.
So it's quite new for us to be
able to have stuff ready on
spreadsheets and to be able
to do it without involving
developer time is just
a really good thing.
And then here's another
example of big data.
So this is every--
the government in the UK is
obsessed with open data mode
because it's a very easy way
to appear transparent.
And so what they start doing
is publishing things like
every public building in England
and Wales and what its
carbon emissions are.
The problem was, they wouldn't
release the full data.
So somebody put in a free
information request and they
got this and then they
sent us the data.
And we use Fusion Tables
to map that.
And what you've e there
is you've got
thousands of public buildings.
And the fact that we
can show those all.
We can color code
them all up by
different types of emissions.
And you can see by how much.
You've got a lot of
buildings there.
The red are the worst
ones, of course.
So let's see if we can go
into some of these.
And you can see where all the
public buildings are as well.
So the type of building
is on the side.
And you can show the information
quite quickly, and
creating something like that
took about 20 minutes.
And again, that's really,
really useful for us.
And then we've got the
Wikileaks data.
Now obviously, Wikileaks was
a lot, a lot of data.
There were three releases.
There was Afghanistan, Iraq,
and the big cables
release at the end.
With the Afghanistan
data, that was
about 90,000 instances.
The Iraq data was 391,000
instances, which makes the
Iraq war the most documented
war in history.
It was in the Pentagon papers,
which came out about Vietnam
was 7,000 documents.
So I think 400,000 documents, we
know everything there is to
know about that war.
And it became obvious quite
quickly the big story was this
huge numbers of people
that died.
Even in this database, where
109,000 people died.
That covers everything from
coalition troops through to
Iraqi civilians.
And we did two things
for this.
We did this thing here, which
is quite beautiful.
Took a lot of technical
time up.
It's basically just presenting
one day in
the life of the war.
We had a Guardian correspondent
writing this
lovely piece to go with it.
You could click on different
events and you could walk
through it and so on.
And we did that.
And then I had this dataset,
which I've been using to do
some analysis on, which was
basically every instance in
which somebody had died.
And there was 66,000 instances
in which at
least one person died.
And we thought, maybe we should
just put that on a
Fusion Table to see
what it shows us.
It might give us something
we can show on the site.
It wasn't something, to be
honest, we spent much time on.
And this is what we got back.
And this is the most
popular interactive
map we've ever done.
Basically, each of these dots
here is an instance where at
least one person died.
And because there are so many,
it gives you a real
sense of the war.
And it tells you more than you
could write 15,000 words on
how many people died in Iraq.
But to actually see them
like that totally
brings it to life.
Now anybody got any thoughts on
which was the most popular
out of those two interactives?
It was this one.
And I think the reason is was
this one, the one that we
haven't spent all that technical
time on, was because
it allows people to explore
the data for themselves.
A lot of the interest in data at
the moment is about people
feeling empowered by data, of
being able to find out about
things they didn't understand
about before
and to discover things.
And that's exactly what
this allows us to do.
It gives you a way to explore
the data yourself.
And you can zoom in and out.
But the great thing about
zooming out is it gives you a
sense of the war in
terms of patterns.
And you see, you're already
starting to get these
groupings as you pull out.
See these roads along
here where there
were lots of IED attacks.
And you get a real
sense of what's
happening across the country.
Now, if you're driving down that
road every day, you might
feel a little bit nervous,
for instance.
And that tells you the story
of the war in a way that
thousands of words wouldn't
necessarily do.
And then one thing we've been
experimenting a lot with
recently is the auto-map
countries.
Now again, for us to draw a map,
traditionally it's been
our Flash guy drawing it, or we
have some stuff where our
developers have done stuff,
but for me to be able to
create a map like this
is a new thing.
And what this is is that our
Foreign Commerce Office, which
is the equivalent of the State
Department here, they issue
travel warnings about
countries that
are safe to go to.
And we thought well, this is
just after Egypt and Libya
kicked off and so on.
We thought, why don't we just
take snapshots of the Foreign
Commerce Office's
travel warnings?
So we scraped the site and we
graded the travel warnings
from don't go here at all to
you can go here, it's fine.
And this is what we got.
And the great thing, actually,
in terms of our style, besides
being a million miles away from
how we would start all
that math anyway, we would use
those kind of borders, we
would use 100 percent
opacity anyway.
And the great thing is you click
on that and you convert
the HTML and that tells
you don't go to Libya.
Or maybe don't go to Afghanistan
either, but you
can go to Iraq or Pakistan
partial.
And so it just gives you--
it's just a useful,
yeah, it's all
troubled, don't go to Iraq.
Just ignore the what's
on the map.
So for us to be able to create
something like that and to put
a story up quite quickly is just
really, really good thing
and this is really
what we're about.
And then there's this
one here, which
Kathryn mentioned earlier.
Now what happens is, the
government every four years
they do this thing called
deprivation indices.
And they're really important in
the UK because they're how
the government hands out
all its funding.
So it's basically a measure
of how poor people are in
different parts of
the country.
But of course they don't use a
boundary that's recognized in
any other way possible.
In the UK we have counties,
which are quite big.
They're a lot bigger than the
counties that you have here.
We also have wards, which may be
similar to the counties you
have here in the States.
Our counties are more
like states,
just to confuse things.
But they also have these little
areas, which are only
used for the states, they're
called lowest input-output
areas, which are basically
small things that maybe
10,000 people go.
So for us to manually map that
would be impossible.
But it's not that we can embed
the official version.
This is the official website.
And if you want to find out
about any of these places,
it's slow, it's clunky,
you don't know what
these places are like.
It's trying to load here.
It's pretty poor.
And it doesn't give you a
picture of the whole country
as a whole, you can't see the
whole country at all.
It doesn't rank it.
It just allows you to zoom down
eventually, see how slow
it is there.
OK, we're getting somewhere.
Anyway, it's pretty poor.
So we thought, we've
got all that data.
It'd be great if we could
do something with it.
So firstly, we had to find the
polygon data, which is a bit
of a pain there.
Eventually we found
an academic.
So each of those little areas
is super out there, but
imagine having data
at that granular
level is really useful.
But we had to get the polygon
data, which was difficult, but
once we had that data, it
meant we could create
something like this.
Click on it and go
to full screen.
So basically, that's everywhere
in England and
Wales, and the deeper the reds
get, the poorer it is and the
deeper the blue get,
the richer it is.
So that's London, it's kicking
off of London, and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is the poorest place
in Britain.
At least now I know
where it is.
But you see, these areas out
here are quite wealthy.
And here you got the
score that was
covered up by the school.
You've got very explanatory data
there, and see over here,
it's quite wealthy at all.
So the great thing is to be able
to show that kind of data
and be able to illustrate
it is really, really a
new thing for us.
And it gives you a picture of
the country you can't get in
any other way.
And it's better than the
official site, so what's not
to like about that?
I'm going to show you one last
thing we did last week.
We're running out of
time, aren't we?
OK.
So last week, we had three
major elections
in the UK on Thursday.
There were two devolved
parliaments, and Wales and
Scotland elected
their members.
But we had to vote in
our voting system.
At the moment in the UK, we
vote first past the post,
which basically the person who
wins the most votes in the
seat wins, that's
how it works.
And but they wanted to change
to a more proportional
system called AV.
It didn't win, it was a disaster
for the campaigners.
But basically we wanted to
create a live results map.
We don't have much time,
so we thought how are
we going to do this?
So we basically created
a merged table.
We merged together one map which
showed-- and the problem
with this, the tricky thing
about it is that in England we
had local authorities, and in
Scotland we had Parliament
seats, and in Wales we all
had Parliament seats.
So we managed to put this all
together using the Fusion
Tables merge thing.
And then we had the data in
separate sheets, merge that
together too.
And basically all we had to do
to change this map, to make it
live, was every 10 minutes just
update the data on the
data sheets.
And that's all we had to do,
just load a new spreadsheet.
We were getting a spreadsheet
download of the results.
Just had to upload that.
And so to turn that map
into a live map.
And people were using
it during the night.
Every time it was like
a 30-second job.
So for us to update that, the
great thing about the
turnaround quite quickly.
And we used the same colors and
styles for the newspaper.
It just made it consistent.
And you can do this
nice stuff.
Everybody voted no apart
from Glasgow.
There you go.
These purples were the only
places that voted yes.
Edinburgh and Glasgow and a
couple of places in London.
There you go.
I suppose I should say that
what we're about as
journalists is that telling
stories and making
data come to life.
And all Fusion Tables
have done is give us
a tool to do that.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHRYN HURLEY: All right.
So just want to go through a
quick summary of what we
showed you today.
So I talked about new features
for trusted testers in the
Fusion Tables API.
These include map feature
styling and Info window
customization.
And James McGill talked about
the new feature in the Google
Maps API and its dynamic
styling.
And I just want to provide
a few links for everyone.
Links to Fusion Tables, Fusion
Table APIs, et cetera.
I'll leave this screen up here
while we take some questions.
So James McGill, if you
want to come up.
And so we have a few minutes
for questions.
And you can also ask questions
of Roger as well.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: Just want
confirm the map is generated
through the styling of
the cached tiles?
JAMES MCGILL: Yes, through
the dynamic styling.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: So if you do
the dynamic styling, you'd
also generate the tiles.
JAMES MCGILL: Yes,
that's correct.
So you still get that
performance gain, even with
the dynamic styles.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: In terms of
tiles size of dimension, we
still only have 128x128 or--
JAMES MCGILL: It's 256x256,
but it's just an
implementation.
it's not something that you
need to worry about.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: OK, what if
I want to push to the mobile.
Would you allow us
to do 64x64 or--
JAMES MCGILL: We've found that
the current tiles work really
well on mobile.
They come down relatively
fast and you get that--
because you're not dealing
with having the number of
client-side objects--
the performance is going
to be better on mobile.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: Second
really quick question.
The Fusion Tables, the
geometry type you
mentioned is KML.
Any other geometry types
you support?
KATHRYN HURLEY: So you can enter
street addresses if you
have location data street
addresses or
lat-longs or points.
What else?
What was that?
Oh, other tools.
And if you have shape files, you
can import shape files to
Fusion Tables using a tool
called Shape Escape.
So it's shpescape.com.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 1: All right.
Thanks.
KATHRYN HURLEY: I think
over there.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 2: Yeah,
I just have a question.
You showed in the API on how
to enter data one at a time
into the Fusion Tables.
Is there a bulk API for loading
gigabytes worth of data?
KATHRYN HURLEY: You can send up
to 500 inserts at the same
time, just separate them
with semicolons.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 2: Do you
have to then check
and resend the 500?
I can obviously see network
timeout or success-failure.
That being if you had to insert,
let's say, 10,000 data
points into a Fusion Table,
so 500 at a time.
Something times out, check
for a response,
have to resend those?
Is there just a bulk upload type
of facility available?
KATHRYN HURLEY: So if the
request is successful, it
returns the row IDs.
If not, then the inserts did
fail and you have to resend
all those inserts.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 2: Right.
But 500 is the maximum at a
time that you can upload.
KATHRYN HURLEY: At this point.
But It would make a great
feature request to be able to
allow more.
Yes.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 3: Question
to James.
In Fusion Tables Layer, if you
have point data, and lots of
it, and you're using tiling, how
do you manage to generate
tiles that don't split the
points and are able to show
them as whole.
JAMES MCGILL: Across
tile boundaries?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 3: Yeah.
JAMES MCGILL: So we use a method
that ensure that if a
point is selected in one tile,
it's also selected in all
other tiles.
So that guarantees that if that
point crosses the border
of multiple tiles because it
would be present in both tiles
or all four tiles, it'll
render correctly.
So people viewing your site,
with the exception of the fact
that Fusion Tables Layer doesn't
let you drag your
markers, for example, they
shouldn't be able to tell the
difference between Fusion Tables
Layer and you having
created these points manually.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 4: Hi.
I have KML that is using the
time line feature, modeling
311 data, pot holes, graffiti,
abandoned cars,
that type of stuff.
I have about 10 years
of that model for
showing in Google Earth.
Can I upload that to Fusion
Tables and still have the time
line feature?
KATHRYN HURLEY: We do have
a story line, but is this
something that you want
to show on a map?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 4: Yeah, I want
them just like they do in
Google Earth.
I want to be able to throw all
those 10 years and close and
open up when the things were
going on, abandoned cars,
graffiti, where they were at
and all the rest of that.
Is Fusion Tables supporting
the time line?
KATHRYN HURLEY: No, you can't
do anything like that in
Fusion Tables.
JAMES MCGILL: But you could
use, for example, some
JavaScript Maps API
to achieve, I
think, the same effect.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 5: The political
boundaries you
showed, is it something that
Google offers for all the
countries or something you
expect the user to create
those political boundaries,
different
states for each country?
JAMES MCGILL: So Google provides
Fusion Tables, but
the data is generally
uploaded by users.
The advantage is that you can
mark that as public, so you
could upload some political
boundaries and allow other
people to fuse that data
with their own data.
And we've seen a lot of people
have uploaded their state
borders, country borders,
political borders and other
people making good use of this,
combining it with other
information they have
to make these maps.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 5: I see.
And one more question.
If our Fusion Table, let's say I
have it on 1 million rows of
data, is there a way the person
who's using it, they
can only see a subset
of the data?
Like I'm logging in from
northeast, I can only see
northeast data.
Somebody's logging in from
southeast, they can only see
southeast data.
But the data that's is the table
has all the data I need.
JAMES MCGILL: So you could use
the example I gave where I
restricted it only show points
where age was greater than 50.
You can of course use spatial
queries as well, so you can
get the current location of the
user and filter it to show
only points within
a certain radius.
Or if you had a bounding box
for the area in which you
wanted, you could filter to
only show those points, so
yeah, I think that's possible.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 5: Thank you.
Good presentation.
JAMES MCGILL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 6: Does
Fusion Tables--
can I optimize any KML
that I put into it?
Let me rephrase.
If I have highly detailed KML,
normally huge files, if I put
them into Fusion Tables, will
that be optimized when I try
to build a map?
Or do I need to strip that
KML and simplify it?
JAMES MCGILL: So we're talking
about simplifying polygons?
AUDIENCE MEMBER 6: Correct.
JAMES MCGILL: Yes.
So, the idea is that when that
data is uploaded to Fusion
Tables, we do offline
simplification to make sure
that it shows efficiently
on a map.
So you don't need to worry about
that as long as you can
keep the KML within
a size that can be
uploaded to Fusion Tables.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 6: Yeah, I'm
not sure I can, but that's
outstanding either way.
JAMES MCGILL: Or consider
splitting it into multiple
files, adding multiple layers,
and that's another way to
aggregate that.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 6: But
still, that sounds
like a great feature.
AUDIENCE MEMBER 7: So for
rendering point data using the
Fusion Table Layer, do you have
any plans to allow for
custom images like custom
marker images?
Because currently you can show
dots of different colors and
different sizes, but if
we could upload--
JAMES MCGILL: I think that would
be compelling to file a
feature request. And if that's
something enough people are
interested in, then maybe it's
something we'll look at.
We're actually out of time, but
think Kathryn and I will
be hanging around I/O.
We'll be at the party tonight.
So if you have any more
questions, come up to us after
and feel free to ask
those questions.
Thank you.